[Musique]
alors quand je fais tout le monde en
parle je sors d'une longue période de
chômage et j'avais demandé à france
télévisions de me reprendre et patrice
duhamel qui était le patron de france
télévisions me convoque au 11 juillet
j'étais encore survient il me dit je
sais pas si je vais prendre moi quand
même patrice ça fait trois ans de
chômage et on se connaît tu le connais
bah ouais mais tu pose des problèmes
j'ai pas quel problème je posais mais je
suis finalement arrivé à convaincre mais
malheureusement le producteur avec qui
je travaillais à l'époque était vraiment
pas très bon et au bout de trois mois il
a fallu admettre que l'émission était
une catastrophe
alors pour un retour c'est pas très
réussi et là j'ai décidé pendant les
vacances de noël de changer de
coproducteur j'ai rappelé catherine
barma mon ex productrice qui revenu qui
est revenu vers moi après s'être fait un
peu prier et là effectivement catherine
un tel talent pour faire venir les
invités sur un plateau que tout de suite
c'est un marché d'autant plus qu'elle
est ruquier comme sniper et ça marchait
plutôt bien et rapidement l'émission a
atteint 2 millions de téléspectateurs
tous les samedis soir à 23 heures
or le concept pas compliqué si tout le
monde en parle bas tout le monde en
parle on parle donc c'est l'agora
c'est une forum du samedi soir si une
espèce de grand mix comme on disait dans
les dîners des années 30 avec une [ __ ]
un archevêque c'est dire le mélange qui
avait un jour côte-à-côte y aller maître
capello et marilyn manson on se demander
si on regardait pas deux chaînes la fois
barma arrive à convaincre la terre
entière de venir se faire emmerder chez
moi et ça marche très très bien
alors bien sûr il ya des bimbos bien sûr
y'a des comics bien sûr y'a tout mais il
ya surtout la spectacularisation de la
culture c'est à dire que entre une bimbo
un humoriste vous pouvez mettre un
écrivain les gens vont regarder parce
qu'ils savent que ça va durer douze
minutes
donc ils se tapent l'écrivain parce
qu'ils savent qu'après ça va de nouveau
devenir rigolo on n'attrape pas les
mouches avec du vinaigre et les
téléspectateurs pour les attraper il
faut les
dire donc on a eu beau albecq michel
houellebecq 38 minutes avec michel
houellebecq incroyable et là l'audience
n'est pas du tout tomber bret easton
ellis tom wolfe
un jour ma vieille mère qui habite à
bormes-les-mimosas un dimanche matin je
l'appelle maman t'as vu l'émission
ah oui j'ai vu l'émission il est
formidable c'est au moule il est
extraordinaire ma mère avait découvert
tom wolfe son grand chapeau blanc à
travers tout le monde en pas et puis
c'est le retour de baffie que j'avais
pas vu depuis double jeu donc il ne fait
plus de sujets comme dans double jeu il
est ainsi et is nigh pfff c'est mortel
tout le monde le connaît c'est le retour
de corti ont fait le blind test avec
corti tout paris venez jouer au blind
test à la fin de l'émission et c'était
un blind test à la dure
dire qu'ils avaient pas un temps de
latence pour trouver l'interprète de la
chanson c'était tout de suite c'est le
premier qui répondait à une tension
absolument incroyable sur le plateau au
moment du blind test tout le monde en
parle c'est le règne des geeks la pause
bisous si les records je voulais
embrasser quelqu'un je me levais l'image
de venir aux il y avait une musique
hollywoodienne et je roule une pelle aux
garçons ou à la fille je vais un jour
bruce willis pause bisous il se penche
vers son acolyte le réalisateur de son
film il dit il est homosexuel mais qui
m'ont c'était quand même très inquiétant
de se poser cette question donc bruce
willis tout le monde d'ali droit la
pause bisous et vince d'un triplé s'il
ya un moment incroyable dans l'émission
kalfon tout de suite leurs jouets donc
on repassait tout de suite il y avait en
bouge pas pendant le jingle baffie passé
son temps à bouger pendant le jingle est
la question qui tue c'est à dire tous
venez noir on voyait plus rien il est
juste une batterie des ca dans la gueule
de l'invité avec la musique de dj coque
est là ont posé la question qui tue ou
la question de la plice 69
quand on arrivait à l'appui 69 up ou
changer et c'est est l'invité qui me
poser une question à moins
alors ce que je peux vous recommander en
tout le monde en parle bas il ya un
moment que j'adore c'est avec michaël
youn un jour on va sur le plateau d'à
côté où julien lepers présenter
questions pour un champion
et là on a foutu un bordel noir j'aimais
bien cette idée d'aller dans un plateau
il ya un côté mel brooks est un côté
surréaliste mais bien cette idée
il y a gorbatchev évidemment au café des
petites mains au moment de faire la
promotion de son livre il ya brad pitt
matt damon les deux fidèles à qui je
propose de la drogue et des filles pour
leur séjour à paris va tout le monde
ment pas magnéto serge et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux